Show me ID. So military ID Jack Jess. So if we're porting for booze, you don't look like this guy
This guy looks like a soldier. Oh
I'm really excited to go camping with you guys why this would be bad stop going through my shit Sarah?
Wait, did you not tell them that we were coming? I was I'm telling them now like they're learning of it right now
Jeremy said we're gonna make six miles into the droids
Don't you something dude, the fun? You can condom this might be your chance to be with Becky. She's always happening for you
I'm slow playing it. Okay, you are know playing it guys spring break and I'm ready to rage let the games begin
If you want we can make down I don't know I'm not gonna take the long way down I'm gonna take the Shawn way down
Obviously didn't hear it that much it's actually really fun
This knife is so sharp
She doing
Did you just oh no
No, no what I have a medical emergency. I need a medevac pronto
I'll get their attention
The fireball was all me did your fucking idiot
That was insane
Wow the fun King you wanted to use it at the hospital
Suppose we can't wait
Sean okay. Yeah
Where's your problem? Trying to you footballer what I'm a bony
Did you just fart? No, it's a seat. Oh my god. Do you have the farts and a boner?
I don't have the farts or a boner. One of those is definitely alive. You're being cock-blocked literally by your own cock